a lot of people see a cat up in a tree
they're just like oh yeah that thing
will get down here in a couple days hey
sweetie how long you been in this tree
but what they don't realize is that
sometimes they don't
i'm shawn sears
and i'm tom otto with canopy cat rescue
and we rescue cats that gets stuck up in
trees
[Music]
cats get stuck in trees a lot we've been
rescuing since about 2008
i'm kidding you would probably do more
cat rescues than anybody in the world
we range from about 375 to 400 rescues
every year
it's okay there's a lot of people that
can't afford to pay your normal arborist
five six seven hundred dollars to rescue
a cat
both tom and i really love cats
he's a total sweetie ginger boy we'll
come out and rescue somebody's cat for
free hi sweetest
all right
canopy cat rescue this is shawn yeah
it's our cat he's climbed up and she's
been up there for three or four hours it
just doesn't look like she's gonna
figure this out
well i think we'll be there in about 45
minutes or so
climbing trees is inherently risky
our average tree height is 100 feet
sometimes they're a lot taller we start
obsess out how the cat's doing as we're
getting close hi
and then hopefully we can proceed with
the rescue
[Music]
we gotta go in a sack how does that
sound
wow
[Music]
the look that we get from the cat owners
face when we hand them their cat back
is just this overwhelming sense of
relief
are you happy to have him back he's
i know you have no idea
we love doing this and we're going to do
it
for as long as we can you said you got a
cat stuck in a tree
we don't really consider ourselves
heroes but we do like to think of
ourselves as just two guys that are out
there restoring the faith in humanity
[Music]
you